[MUSIC PLAYING]
- All right, so welcome.
I'm very, very happy to
have a chance to be here.
Now let's get
ourselves in the mood.
I'm going to talk about
pain and suffering today.
I hope I don't cause
you too much of that,
but we will see about
that, by the way.
So this is a famous painting
by Bruegel, Triumph of Death.
Some of you may know it.
If I talk about every
single painting I show,
I'll be here for three hours.
So I won't do that.
But I just want to point
out some very, very
important matters here.
So Bruegel did this
painting in 1562.
It's one of the-- it
was about in response
to the wave of plagues
that were ravaging Europe,
but also the religious wars.
Catholics were
killing Protestants.
Protestants were
killing Catholics.
It was a time of incredible
pain and suffering.
In fact, I want to talk
about this a little bit later
in the talk today.
But as Foucault points out
in Discipline and Punishment,
the punishments
were public then,
whereas the punishments
today are often
people are locked away
and being punished.
But one of the really
striking things
here is on the right
side is an army
of pretty much skeletons
walking forward holding a cross.
There were people being
grabbed at a table, who they're
in the midst of playing cards.
One thing that really interests
me-- and again a lot of people,
even people who know something
the period don't really kind
of think enough
about, in my opinion--
is the way that people were
executed in the period.
Often if you were even just
caught like stealing something,
you were executed by
being put on a wheel.
And that meant
your arms and legs
were broken as your body
was put on the wheel.
You were out in the air
like this, obviously
in huge and terrible pain.
It could take days to die.
Birds would pluck out your eyes.
Insects would eat your flesh.
If your screams bothered
the people in your family,
it was too bad.
Everyone had to
listen to you scream.
Are we having fun yet?
All right, now here's a
detail from this painting.
But again, I hope not to
cause you too much pain today.
But one of my interests
in this project
and one of my interests
in my life in general
is ideas about
pain and suffering.
I'm quite interested
as a philosopher--
this is partly due
to my work in prison
and my commitment to what
my activist friends call
the transformation or
transcending rather
of the punishment paradigm.
But I'm interested in
how we human beings
think and respond to
our own suffering,
how we think or ignore
the suffering of others,
even the suffering
that we cause others,
and how we respond to
the suffering of others
or, in fact, ignore it.
Now a few years ago,
I was getting involved
in this anti-carceral activism.
But I realized in my day job
as a historian of philosophy
that no one had thought
seriously at all
about the history of the notion
of suffering and its relation
to philosophy.
So this project of mine,
"Feeling the Way to Truth--
Women, Reason, and
the Development
of Modern Philosophy," grew
out of that set of thoughts.
Now basically, one of
the things I want to do
is I think that we need to
do a complete reconsideration
of history, of
philosophy, especially
the development of early
modern philosophy as it's told.
And I think in this
audience, not a lot of people
probably know or
remember the details
of the development of modern
philosophy and the story
about that.
So let me remind you.
Now this is a parody.
It's called The Myth
of such and such.
But as a parody, it
would be only funny,
except for the fact that it
still remains pretty true.
So this is the parody.
And I hope you think
it's as amusing as I do,
but never mind.
I wish I had a Judi
Dench kind of voice here.
"It came to pass that the Earth
was without form and void.
And darkness covered
the face of the earth.
And the creators saw that
the darkness was evil.
And he spoke out
in the darkness,
saying, "Let there be light."
And there was light.
And he called the
light Renaissance.
And thus it was that the
continental rationalist
came to be.
So Descartes begat Spinoza,
and Spinoza begat Leibniz.
And thus it was that
the British empiricists
came to be so that Hobbes
begat Locke, and Locke begat
Berkeley, and
Berkeley begat Hume.
And then it was that there arose
the great sage of Koenigsberg,
the great Immanuel,
Immanuel Kant, who
though neither empiricist
nor rationalist
was likened to both.
He, it was, who combined
the eye of the scientist
with the mind of
the mathematician.
And this, too, the creator
saw and saw that it was good.
And he sent goodly
men and scholars
true to tell the story
wherever men should henceforth
gather to speak of sages past."
Now, this was
written in 1981 just
at the moment when people were
reconsidering this narrative.
But it still is strikingly
embraced by many people
in many departments.
This is the kind of
history philosophy
that's typically told.
And if you doubt that, I just
point out that, for example,
the book on the right here,
The Norton Introduction
to Philosophy, was supposed to
be the great new introduction
to philosophy.
It's edited by very, very
serious philosophers.
In fact, one of them
is a friend of mine.
They talked to a lot of people
about what kind of introduction
to philosophy they needed.
It was published
three years ago.
And it contains 1,168 pages.
It starts with
Aristotle and Plato,
main topics in the
history of philosophy,
and works through those topics.
So it covers 2,400
years of philosophy.
But nowhere in any
of its pages is there
a mention of a person who
wrote in Arabic or a person--
a Jewish thinker, not
a single woman author
until the mid 20th century.
It entirely ignores anyone
except the canonical figures.
So it also, by the way, talks
about political philosophy
and the development of
political philosophy
and does not mention, as
most people don't, the very
important 19th century
authors who were former slaves
in the United States, who had
many really interesting things
to say, but again whose
voices have not been heard.
Now it's a really good
question, I think,
and I think for you folks,
like how did this come to pass?
How did this story
get to be told?
By the way, these two other
books are standard collections
as well.
Same thing.
Not a single woman.
A friend of mine
and I did an op-ed
in the Washington Post,
which really kind of got
their blood circulating.
And everyone now
is going to include
a woman in the next edition
or two of these books.
All right, so how did
this story get set?
Well, in a way, it's
surprisingly easy.
Post-Kantian German
philosophers created a narrative
about the history
of philosophy that
highlighted what
they consider to be
the most important
philosophical questions.
That is, they told a story that
conveniently led to themselves
as the heroes.
In his 1820 lectures on
the history of philosophy,
Hegel credits Descartes with
breaking holy with the past
and setting the stage
for the greatness
of his own philosophy, writing--
this is astonishing.
He writes, "Germanic philosophy,
IE, modern philosophy
begins with Descartes."
And in his lectures
in the 1820s--
sorry 1847, rather,
Schopenhauer also
insists that "our
excellent Descartes
is the instigator of the
subjective investigation
and in this the father
of modern philosophy."
So Hegel and then Schopenhauer
after him kind of told
the story about how
Descartes started
something that ended with them.
Now Kuno Fischer you
probably haven't heard of,
but was an extremely popular
lecturer and philosopher
in Germany.
He was in Heidelberg, wrote
several volumes, including--
this is this
multi-volume edition
of The History of Philosophy.
It's actually
really pretty good.
No wonder he was
considered a good teacher.
It tells this big, grand story.
But according to him, Descartes
made a fundamental and complete
renovation of philosophy.
It's actually, it points,
unintentionally hilarious.
He compares Descartes to
Faust, in Goethe's Faust,
who goes off into the world
and wants to discover nature
as opposed to read books.
Now it strikes me
that that's not
that complimentary to
Descartes, but never mind.
Now also this story gets
going by these German thinkers
in mid-late 19th century.
And then it's picked up by very,
very serious and again very
well-educated and
thoughtful philosophers
in France and Germany.
I'll just mention
Ernst Cassirer here,
because he really was a
very, very fine philosopher.
Ignore the German.
I was going to translate
it, but you can basically
get the point.
The basic point is that the
17th century philosophy--
and you can see
underlined here systems.
He wants to see 17th
century philosophy is
a series of systems.
He mentions here Descartes,
Malebranche, Spinoza, Leibniz,
Bacon and Hobbes and so on.
So again it's a
story of philosophy.
It's a series of beads
on a string, all of which
are great systems.
I think I underlined the
bit that says system.
So he's interested in
the history of philosophy
was set then as a
series of systems.
Now you can imagine that
with this story told
for over 150 years, this is
what philosophers taught.
This is what philosophers did.
It's really hard to
shake this loose, right?
But a lot of us these days--
I'm by no means the
only one, in fact by no
means the first one--
are trying to think about
how to diversify philosophy.
There's a number of websites.
There's a lot of
good work being done.
This is just a website
for a center I started.
It has my three passions,
including rethinking justice.
I'd love to tell you
about Aisha Elliot.
She's one of my best friends.
She was incarcerated
for 25 years,
but never mind about that.
She is great.
But I think I mentioned
to my Radcliffe colleagues
last week about the Oxford
Philosophical Concepts.
And Meredith mentioned that.
But here are some of the
first volumes still out.
What I didn't
mention, by the way,
is that the new volume
that's coming out
is going to be the longest
of all of them yet.
And that's the one
on evil, which I
think is appropriate possibly.
Now the New Oxford
Histories of Philosophy
are again attempting to
get very serious scholars
to do editions of books that
have not been available.
The first book in the series
is on Mexican philosophy,
as Meredith mentioned.
One of the next
ones coming along
is on Martin Delany, the man
whose photograph is the top.
He's a black nationalist
riding in the mid 19th century
considered to be really
brilliant political theorist.
The Principia
Philosophiae is the title
of a book by Anne Conway, the
philosopher I'm working on.
Some of us are also
doing a new translation
in addition of her work.
So there's a lot of work
coming along the way.
Now back to my project.
So one of the
things I hope I will
be able to do in my project
is to shake some things loose,
especially shake lose the
relationship between early
modern philosophy and Descartes
and late medieval philosophy
and also this nonsense
that Descartes
created the subjective turn.
So one of the things
I really hope to do
is by killing these
sacred cows, for example,
the sacred cow of Descartes
inventing the subjective turn
and the idea that--
actually one thing
that interests
me, I haven't mentioned
yet, is that we're
supposed to believe that
the Enlightenment thinkers
like Locke and
Rousseau and so on
invented the notion of
equality and dignity and so on.
In my opinion, it's quite clear
that these late medieval women
I've been working
on-- it's all there.
The roots of those ideas
are embedded very deeply
into late medieval thought.
Now obviously I can't tell
this whole story today.
But I want to tell you--
I want to focus just
on one part of it,
the part I thought
you might find
most interesting, namely
the bit on suffering
and particularly the
relationship between suffering
and virtue.
OK, suffering's deep background.
Now I picked this.
This is Zeus.
He's a very manly man.
And so I thought it
would be good to use him
as an example of an
ancient notion of virtue.
The Latin virtus, the
original sense means strength.
It means power.
In fact, in 17th
century philosophy,
for a very long time virtus
was used to talk about force.
It was a word that was used
to think about physics.
It came to be obviously
primarily related
to being virtuous as
we think of it now.
But it's important to realize
that this notion of strength
was basic.
OK, now one of the obsessions
of ancient philosophers
Plato, Aristotle, and
so on was the idea
of how to live a
proper life, how
to live a virtuous life-- in
short, how to get life right.
So Plato, for example, says,
"So long as we keep to the body,
there is no chance of
our ever attaining truth,
because the body fills us with
loves and desires and passions
of all sorts so that we never
get an opportunity to think
about anything at all."
Now, this is the
Phaedo where Plato
was particularly anti-body.
It's less clear in
some other dialogues.
But still, this is
the one that kind of
was set and very influential.
So let's just be clear
about what Plato is saying.
He's saying that
reason, understanding
it's sometimes translated
as, has to deny the body.
You cannot be tainted
by corporeal matters
if you're going to attain to
and actually focus on eternal
truths.
So the only way to
get things right
is to deny the body, to have
strength to overcome the body.
So if you attend to
the body, then it
follows that you
can't have virtue.
You can't get things right.
Your life is going
to suck, in short.
Now interesting in
ancient literature,
there's lots of
options for women.
And women can be agents.
There are goddesses.
Medea is a demigod.
She kills her children
before taken up to Heaven.
Why was she taken up to
Heaven despite the fact
that she has killed
her children?
Because she is heroic.
She's defended her honor.
By the way, Toni Morrison was
quite interested and influenced
by her in writing Beloved.
By the time we get to early--
actually let me just skip
back here for a second
and just tell you.
But already at this point,
already in ancient literature
there is this tendency
to think of women
as not as fully capable of
being rational, as fully capable
of being powerful.
There are powerful
women, but it's still
a problem to attain virtue.
Now let's look at some
of the reasons for that.
According to
Aristotle, the female
is, as it were, a deformed male.
According to the best medical
doctors in the period,
medical philosophers,
because the female body
has an imbalance of
fluids proven by the need
to shed blood monthly,
it is incomplete.
Galen, writing 600
years later, one
of the most important
medical philosophy
thinkers in medieval Europe,
puts it very clearly.
"We shall look upon
the female state
as being a deformity,
the one which
occurs in the ordinary
course of nature.
Just as mankind is the most
perfect of all animals,
so within mankind the man is
more perfect than the woman."
In response to an
obvious question
he's asked, why would the
creator purposely make
half the human race imperfect
and as it were mutilated,
the answer he gives, "He
made man complete and woman
incomplete so that she
could be made complete
through bearing children."
Anne Clement of Alexandria,
a very important thinker--
and again there's
hundreds of examples
of this kind of saying--
puts it very succinctly.
I really like this
way of putting it,
as a way of
summarizing the view.
"To do, to act, to be
an agent, to be virtuous
is the mark of a man.
To suffer is the
mark of a woman."
And one of the things I
want to point out here
is just how fluids
play an important role
for these medical scientists.
OK, now don't have
time to go into it.
But one of the things that
we really need to remember
is in early Christianity, there
were radical different ways
of being a Christian.
Lots of women were actually
out there reading and writing.
Elaine Pagels talks about this.
There were lots of different
versions of being a Christian,
including some that
actually, believe it or not,
read Genesis as having Eve
be the good guy, so to speak.
I can talk about that later with
people if they're interested.
But it was a common
reading of Genesis.
So there are many different
versions of early Christianity.
And I think I would remind
you that there's two creation
stories in Genesis.
One has Adam and Eve being
created at the same time.
It's the second creation
story, inconsistent clearly
with the first, where Eve is
taken from the rib of Adam.
Now that in itself is
the one that got said.
OK, so Augustine.
By the fourth
century BC, the fate
of women from medieval
Europe was sealed.
This is mostly thanks to
the brilliant-- no denying--
brilliant, prolific, and
utterly mean-spirited person
Augustine of Hippo.
The reading of the
Genesis and the gospels
that Augustine helped
codify made it clear
that women were physically
and morally inferior to men.
The arguments for these claims
were straightforward enough.
Eve's morality and
her moral inferiority
follow from the fact that she
was created second and sinned
first.
Now notice the
image on the right.
She's pulled out from--
she comes out of Adam's Eve
and within like almost
the same temporal frame,
right, is already
starting to sin.
But also Eve's
physical inferiority,
which is closely related
to her moral inferiority
was to make her
morally perverse.
So let's think about
that a little bit more.
So the punishment that God
gave Eve involved her fertility
and in that sense
her body, which
was supposed to lie at
the core of her nature.
And given her inferiority, she
clearly needed ruling over,
as we see in Genesis.
"To the woman, he
said, I will greatly
multiply your pain in
childbirth, in pain, you
will"--
sorry-- "in pain you will
bring forth children.
Yet"-- and I underline--
"your desire will be
for your husband.
And he will rule over you."
Again, if we had
more time to talk,
it would be very interesting
to talk about the utter kind
of horror of this.
Eve's nature is to
desire her husband.
But by following
her nature, she is
forced to suffer in
childbirth and take on,
as it were, the inferiority
of her female form.
So women after the
fall are perverse.
Their nature is perverse.
For our purposes, it's important
that the punishment of women
is to be more rooted
in their bodies,
to be more inclined to
desire and to suffer.
It followed, of
course, that they
had no capacity for virtue,
at least not by themselves.
And again, you know
these passages.
I'll only read a couple.
Women should remain
silent in churches.
They are not allowed to speak,
but must be in submission,
notice as the law says.
Corinthians, women
should remain silent--
sorry.
Corinthians 11:2-9, "For I want
you to understand that Christ
is the head of every man, and
the husband is the head of his
wife, for a man ought not to
have his head veiled since he
is the image and
reflection of God.
But woman is a
reflection of man.
Indeed, man was
not made for woman,
but woman for man," and so on.
Again, the same idea that
you find in Aristotle, which
is woman is a deformed man.
OK, nor did Augustine's--
he pretty much
single-handedly, in my opinion,
gave us this mean-spirited,
misogynistic version
of Christianity.
But he also, of course, was a
beautiful, wonderful writer.
And his confessions written at
the end of the fourth century
set the stage for all
of medieval Europe's
kind of spiritual ways of
thinking about spirituality.
In fact, some scholars
maintain that it's
in Augustine we find the
first subjective turn,
arguably whether it's like
Descartes, but still there.
Now, so for of
medieval Europe then,
these spiritual meditations,
the sort that Augustine set up,
were the way-- these were the
way in which one meditated.
Now, I don't want to
go into the details.
This is like a part of
the philosophy of it all.
But one of the things that--
the assumption here and one
of the really important points
that underlies a lot of this
is that in order to attain
virtue or to get life right,
we must explore ourselves--
this was for Augustine--
explore ourselves
and our beliefs.
And this exploration
requires-- in fact,
it's a whole long
list of things.
These are some of the
more important ones.
So after Augustine persuasively
argued that women were not
capable of doing this sort
of thing, they didn't.
They may have tried to do it.
They may have actually
written lots of things.
But we have no
evidence that they did.
None of these materials, if they
tried to write or did write,
have survived.
But-- and this is where
I get really excited.
And this is the beginning
of my own new work,
is that something really odd
happened in the 12th century,
actually between the
12th and 14th centuries.
Women began to write
and even to teach.
You can tell they did
because prominent men started
protesting.
[LAUGHTER]
The chancellor of the
University of Paris
writes, "the female sex is
forbidden to teach in public.
All women's teachings,
particularly formal teaching
by word and by writing, is to be
held suspect unless it has been
diligently examined and
much more fully than men's.
The reason is clear.
Following Eve's legacy,
women are easily
seduced and determined
seducers and because it is not
proved that they are
witnesses to divine grace."
This last bit is really
insulting, right?
OK, so how could
this problem arise?
How could it arise that women
were suddenly in a position
to be writing things
and be taken seriously
and be taken so seriously
that the chancellor
of the bloody University of
Paris has to complain about it?
There was, in short, a radical
shift in religious modes.
Beginning in the 12th century
and developing steadily
over the next few, there was
what's called a new genre--
a new genre of
spiritual meditative
exercises with the express
goal of teaching readers
how to identify with
the suffering of Christ.
The shift in
religious practices--
and it was radical--
is what scholars call
effective meditations.
This is what one scholar
writes about this.
The meditations "ask the
readers to imagine themselves
present at the scenes
of Christ's suffering
and to perform compassion
for that suffering victim
in a private trauma
of the heart.
These were crafted to
teach their readers,
through iterative affective
performance, how to feel."
So I think it's--
these images are
really incredible.
This image is, in fact, by--
this is a book by a professor
here at Harvard, Jeffrey
Hamburger, who discovered
this cache of art
by women in a monastery and
really basically painting
about their religious
and spiritual lives.
Notice the blood.
Notice the kind of blood
and guts, so to speak,
of this image on the left.
On the right is an image
from the early 16th century.
But you see suddenly-- and this
has not been true before around
1100--
Christ is represented
as a suffering entity.
He's not the King of Heaven
anymore with the crown on.
This is kind of like, this is my
imitation of the Christ before.
It's like la-dee-da, if
you know the end of Monty
Python and the Holy Grail.
But he is a
passionate human being
who has suffered for
the sake of humanity.
This is an example of just like
one of hundreds of examples.
But not only did
women write, women
told people to make
books for them.
This is Mary going--
this is made by, in
fact, a friend of mine
who's working on this.
This is meditations that
were written for the Poor
Clares, the female version
of St. Francis women,
so to speak after
Clare, his friend.
And they asked that a
meditation be written
showing Mary going out and
preaching and giving money
and so on and aid to the poor.
I made the mistake of
not copying a folio which
is really wonderful.
In this same volume,
there is actually
a drawing of Jesus kind
of sitting at the table.
And Mary's washing dishes.
She's made dinner for him.
There is one of my favorite
people that I am working on
and kind of just discovered
in the past few years
is this wonderful person,
Julian of Norwich.
And this is-- I show
this, because she
was what's called an anchoress.
Many women in this period
would anchor themselves,
would enclose themselves in
a small part of a church.
They basically
lived in this room.
But they also-- many of
them had little windows
and would actually be
spiritual advisors to people.
In fact, a couple of people--
a couple of these
women became famous
as kind of the therapists,
the shrinks for the town.
People would come up and talk
to them about their husband
or problem child.
But notice what Julian says.
"Just because I am a
woman, must I therefore
believe that I must not tell
you about the goodness of God
when I saw his wish that
it should be known?"
So this is the argument.
God was showing them truths.
And it was their obligation
to share the truths
that God was showing them.
And how was God showing
them these truths?
God was showing
them these truths
by their capacity to identify
with the suffering of Jesus,
the suffering of Mary, the
suffering of other people
so they could actually
take on the insides
of these spiritual beings.
Notice what she says.
And this is common.
"I wanted to suffer with him
and with others who loved him.
And I wanted his pains to be
my pains with compassion."
So one of the things that
is really striking to me
when I first understood this
is compasio, to suffer with,
was invented in this period.
The notion of compassion
was not a notion
that was prominent and current.
So suddenly the idea, the
goal to be compassionate,
to suffer with people
becomes prominent.
Now again, if I talked about
all the art and images,
I'd be here too long.
And I may be here
too long anyway.
In fact, somebody is going to
have to tell me about the time.
But this pieta is one of
the most striking objects
I've ever seen.
One of the things I
learned is that pietas--
who knew-- I didn't--
that didn't exist until 1300.
And they began--
probably the first pietas
were created by women in
the Rhineland of Germany.
It was a function of kind
of women wanting to in a way
see themselves in God.
So what's striking to me
about this work in my--
a little art class sometimes
I teach at Columbia--
it's art appreciation really.
What's striking to me about this
is the focus is not on Jesus.
Jesus is dead.
Sure, he suffered.
But the focus is on Mary at
the kind of moment of her loss
and the horror of the
recognition of her misery.
So we see him through her.
But she is the primary
conduit of our suffering.
We compasio.
We are compassionate with her.
Now one of the striking
things that these women did--
and actually Caroline Bynum
first wrote about this.
She has this beautiful book
called Jesus as Mother.
And I remember
reading that title
and thinking like, this
is too weird for words.
But basically what these women
were particularly inclined
to do and men did,
too-- in fact,
this tradition began
in monasteries by men--
is to think of Jesus
as a mother who suckled
the breast of his children.
And the head of monasteries
saw themselves in the same way.
It's kind of transgender
goodness knows what.
Now this is a book from 1616
I've found searching around.
And look at the top.
This is by the Jesuits.
This is probably-- I
can't remember actually
the details now.
This is probably Ignatius.
And what's he doing?
He's lactating.
You see his breast?
And actually it's
very interesting
how he is kind of female, right?
You don't see-- there's
no indication of a penis.
So he is lactating,
sending his milk out,
so that his children might
suckle and follow him.
It's pretty wild stuff.
OK, so let's rethink, then, the
meditative spiritual exercises.
Everything we said
before is still true.
But we have this
new requirement.
The virtue seeker now
must analyze, categorize,
and understand her feelings.
That's what these affective
meditations are about.
They're to teach you how
to feel in the right way.
It's there to teach you-- so
at first you're sympathetic,
but then you have
to become more so.
You have to focus so much on
the suffering of the people who
have suffered for you that
you actually sometimes bleed
yourself.
In fact, you know people know
about Saint Francis's stigmata.
Women had had them for a century
before Saint Francis got them.
They would suddenly
spontaneously bleed as it were.
So you had to--
the truth seeker had to analyze,
categorize, and understand
her feelings.
They had to suffer with Jesus
and other religious figures.
And the meditator, in short,
had to feel their way to virtue.
Suddenly, the feeling was
primary and important.
Again from Julian, "For if
I look solely at myself,
I am really nothing.
But as one of
humankind in general,
I am oneness of love
with all others.
For upon this oneness of
love depends the life of all,
for God is all that is good, and
God has made all that is made,
and God loves all
that he has made."
Here are some other
passages I can have you
kind of look at as
you're going along here.
I want to, though, talk
a little bit about how
kind of astonishing this is.
So what do we have here?
In the past, in the ancient
notion of women and women's
bodies, to suffer, to be related
to your body, to have affect
was to guarantee that
you couldn't find virtue.
And now suddenly that's
been turned on it's head.
And historians of
the period talk
a lot about why this happened.
You can do a kind of good
Marxist historical reading
of this.
Enormous suffering,
suddenly actually--
long story about that.
So there were social
and economic reasons
for this surely.
But the fact is that there
was this effective radical
transition, this change.
So that having a capacity to
think through your feelings,
to analyze your feelings,
to worry about your feelings
was itself the means to
think about and understand
fundamental truths
about the world, right?
So suddenly note,
reason is important.
It's not as if reason
doesn't come into play.
You have to think through
arguments sometimes.
And at the end, for some
of these meditations,
you actually do have to kind
of think through and reason
about the nature of God.
So theology still plays a role.
But you have this punctuated.
So it's philosophy and
reason, as it were,
punctuated by
analysis of feeling.
In fact, during the troubadours,
the kind of love poetry that
was written in the so-called
12th century Renaissance,
many people--
there's actually some
very interesting cases
where people say,
I felt all of these
complicated and
conflicting ways,
but couldn't
understand my feelings.
And within a 20
or 30-year period,
people were thinking
about naming feelings,
naming emotions, naming affects.
And women have a very
important role to play in that.
So let's just focus a little
bit on what Julian says here.
God shows her "all
that is made."
Now this is not--
this is philosophy.
This is metaphysics.
God is letting
her know something
about the nature of reality.
Also notice that when--
people talk about
Julian in this way.
And it's fascinating.
What she's doing is, as
it were, reading her body.
She suffers.
She suffers for the
suffering of other people.
She thinks about suffering
as something that she does
and she thinks other people do.
So there's a way in which she's
reading her body and from that.
And she says, here.
"And when the bodily
vision stopped,
the spiritual vision remained
in my understanding."
So it's not just about the body.
It's about the body
and the possibility
for the body and
the truths that it
comes to in thinking
about feelings
and so on to produce ideas that
the understanding can embrace.
Her insights, she says, are
"universal and addressed"--
notice-- "to all,
because we are all one."
Again, I can't focus
on this too much here.
But she says this
and this woman,
this 17th century
woman philosopher
Anne Conway I'm working on.
These women-- especially Conway.
It's clear that all human
beings are capable of dignity.
You don't have to be a
Christian to come to truth.
She says the Jews, Turks--
that is, the Muslims--
and Christians
can all understand
what's true about the world.
I mean, she's devoted
and committed to an idea
that all human beings are
capable of loving one another.
And then finally Julian,
"If I look solely at myself,
I am really nothing, but as
one of humankind in general,
I am openness of love with
all others," and so on.
But there are some
who disagreed.
And Aquinas, for example--
it's very interesting.
There's a whole discussion
in Aquinas and Scotus based
on the quotation from Psalm.
"The just man will rejoice
when he sees divine vengeance."
And I threw this in, but Aquinas
is clear about the fact that
when the blessed are in heaven--
so you're lucky enough to get
to heaven--
one of the joys
you feel in heaven
is hearing the screams
of the people in hell.
"They do rejoice
in the suffering
of the damned as a manifestation
of divine justice."
So not everyone
agreed with compasio.
OK, so the metaphysics of love.
I haven't decided
what to call this.
My students want me to call
it the metaphysics of love.
It sounds a little
bit too 1960s to me,
but maybe I'll go with that.
I can hear from people later on.
But it's surely a
metaphysics of affect.
So one of the major
parts of my book--
and I'm not going to talk
about this any more than I have
today--
is to talk about the metaphysics
that these people are committed
to, of an underlying
vital divine force
that all human beings have,
that suffering produces
an analysis of one's feelings
and one's, as it were,
love for other human beings.
God has made the world
so that all human beings
stand in sympathetic
harmony to one another.
And if you understand
that, then you've
understood something fundamental
about God and about the nature
of the world.
This mosaic from the
12th century in Rome
is a really nice example of
this interconnection of things.
Now in closing, I want
to make two points.
One is I have a
bit of a problem.
If I want to kind of
rethink and rewrite
the history of philosophy,
which I do, I can, I think,
very easily show that these
women had a major force
and played a major role in the
influence and the development
of ideas.
No problem.
The problem is the
way they wrote.
So this is from Marie
de Gournay, a very
famous in her time feminist.
She was a skeptic, really out
there, radical, much hated.
She was kind of trolled
in the early 17th century.
"Blessed are you,
reader, if you do not
belong to the sex of those who
are deprived a proper education
so that ignorance, slavery, and
the capacity to play the fool
are established as
woman's only happiness."
Now I'm really taken
by this, because one
of the problems with Julian and
Teresa of Avila, somebody else
I work on--
did I mention them before?
Yeah, here are
the three people--
here are the other people I'm
going to work on in the book.
There might be
somebody else involved.
But all of these
women are very--
except for Anne Conway, who's
writing in the 17th century--
are very inclined to
say, I'm just a woman.
And what do I know?
But here and then they zap you
with some interesting insight.
But what worries me is the
fact that their writings, then,
are not as philosophically
straightforward.
They practice a genre that
lots of philosophers and people
who think about philosophy
seriously don't kind of
appreciate very much.
But let me tell you
in a couple minutes
about some work I've done.
I've already written about
this, but again about Descartes.
Now when we think
about Descartes,
we think about
that he's supposed
to have invented the
self-reflecting individual,
right?
And that happens, the
so-called cogito argument.
I think, I am--
I think, therefore I am.
In the discourse, it's, I
think I am, comma, I am,
in the Meditations.
But this begins with the
evil deceiver argument.
And everyone who's looked around
for the source of Descartes'
meditations have been
stunned and then amazed
that there seems to be no
sources for this, right?
They've looked at Ignatius,
because Descartes was
educated in a Jesuit school.
And Ignatius-- they all
did spiritual meditations.
And there's nothing in
the spiritual exercises
that Ignatius of Loyola
wrote or anything
like Descartes' meditations.
So they looked around for
a great man as the source.
But nobody looked around
for a great woman.
In all of some of
the major arguments
in Descartes' meditations--
I have a paper on this--
are all in Teresa.
And moreover, Teresa
was a rock star.
Everyone knew her.
The Jesuits loved her.
Now, I can't go
into the details.
But here's an account
of the deceived--
many, many books were
written about her.
And many books were summarizing
her spiritual meditations.
But just like
Descartes' meditations,
she thinks that she's making
some headway towards the truth.
And then the devil comes out
and goes boogie, boogie, boogie.
Let me take your attention
off your meditative exercises.
And then look what she does.
Like Descartes'
meditator, she finally
decides to analyze herself
and her subjective truths
in the right kind of way.
And the poor dejected
devils have to we.
I kind of even feel sorry
for this first devil here.
Now Beyonce.
You can't have a lecture about
divinity without including
Beyonce.
So why Beyonce?
Because Teresa was the
Beyonce of the 17th century.
You might not like her, but
you could not ignore her.
And you had to admire her.
And I say that
because her books--
I mean, all of her writings
originally in Spanish
were translated into Latin and
were spread all over Europe.
Here's someone-- again,
I don't have time
to read all this stuff.
But here's someone
who says, the elements
of the most profound philosophy
are explained in your text.
But here-- and this is
part of my problem now--
because she was so
damn clear at times,
damn moving at times,
many people thought
that she must
be in league with the devil.
But it was her clarity
that actually--
the clarity that was in her work
got her in trouble in a way.
And people complained
about that.
So one of the reasons--
when she kept writing, one of
the reasons she became a little
bit less clear in
cases, I think,
is because she had to kind of
be a little bit more meandering,
rather-- sorry--
in order to kind of
accommodate these problems.
Just to make clear how
incredibly famous she was,
this is one of the many English
translations of her work.
And I just want to point out
this incredible little bit here
that I've found in
the Folger Library.
"It presently
appeareth a new wonder
that a weak woman should be
so courageous as to undertake
So great an essay and so
wise and of such efficacy
that she should bring it to pass
and rob the hearts of those who
treated with her," and so on.
Now notice that there
is always how smart she
is, how awesome she is, how
clear-headed she is, but also
how she wins the
hearts, because she
does that with her sort
of constant very, very
touching personal touches.
So she was this great
woman writing books.
But she also had to
present her philosophy,
think about her philosophy
in a gendered way
so that it be taken seriously.
So my question then, and
something I really look forward
to talking to people
about over the year,
is sort of how to think about
the non-philosophical ways
in which some of these texts,
though richly philosophical,
should be thought about.
Now in conclusion-- I have a
conclusion and then a coda.
And my conclusion is
just that obviously--
I hope I've convinced you
by just the little bit I've
said that obviously the standard
narrative of the development
of early modern philosophy
has to be rethought.
The subjective turn
happened earlier.
Many of the features that we
attribute to enlightenment
thinkers, which I can barely
even talk about today,
extend throughout this period.
I have lots of questions
to my colleagues,
and I really look
forward to talking
to you about how best to treat
this material going ahead.
But I want to end my
lecture, because this
is my tendency these days,
with something that we
should be thinking about--
the pain and suffering now.
Now we can look at
Bruegel's Triumph of Death.
And we can sort
of think about how
we kind of confront and
don't confront suffering
in life, right?
So one of the things I
want to make very clear
is something that is that.
There's so much pain
and suffering around us
that we actually sometimes
don't have the opportunity
to think as much about compasio
as these late medieval women
did.
These late medieval
women were focused
on how we think about ourselves
in relation to the world.
So just a couple quick little
facts, one to do with Harvard.
I wrote an op-ed
three years ago,
because there had been
a big push at Columbia
to divest from the
private prison industry.
Now, if you don't know, the
private prisons run almost all
of the detention centers.
So the poor immigrants
that we worry a lot about--
we worry and gnash our
teeth about the fact that
the children are being ripped
from their mothers and fathers
and so on and so forth--
we really care about that.
But how many people
know that most of them
are sent off to private prisons?
They're private.
The whole point is for
them to make money.
And they make
millions of dollars.
The CEO of CoreCivic--
what a lovely name for it--
makes something like
$5 million a year, OK?
Now this is a fact
that we might think,
well, OK there's lots of
really bad stuff that happens.
What can we do about it?
But the fact is, Harvard
University, for example,
still invest in the
private prison industry.
In fact, Harvard-- part
of the point of my op-ed
is-- and I pick out
Harvard because it
has such a bad history.
Harvard didn't even
divest from South Africa
during the apartheid
period, right?
And it won't even
consider divesting
from the private
prison industry.
So when you're not
sleeping at night
because you can't bear the
thought of these poor children
being ripped from
their mother or father,
realize that your salary,
if you're at Harvard,
or this nifty podium
here is partly
paid for on the backs
of these children.
Whoa, this is heavy.
And then for those of
you who are not Harvard,
you don't escape
my wrath either.
Just 3.5 miles from
where I'm standing now
is the Suffolk County
jail, which houses--
it's really hard
to get information
about some of these places--
775 people who are there.
Now let's just think
about what jails are like.
And again, a lot of
people don't confront this
as much as I think they should.
About probably 2/3 of
the people in that jail
are there because
they can't pay bail.
So if the same person who
did the same crime who
has the money to
pay bail gets to sit
at home waiting for
his or her crime,
but the people in
Suffolk County who
are there who can't pay bail
are being abused, right?
In fact, a lot of the more
vulnerable of the people
are being put in
solitary confinement.
And one of the things I learned
is that Massachusetts-- so
you can think that you're
from Massachusetts,
it's a pretty liberal,
progressive state.
It's not good on
solitary confinement.
And there is no movement
to change the bail system.
Now, some of you may know
this incredible story
about Kalief Browder, and
this is my last little slap
in the face.
This was in The New Yorker.
But here's this young man who
turned out to be innocent,
but was arrested for basically
looking black and having
a backpack, was thrown
in jail, face was a mess.
He was put in
solitary confinement
because he was so vulnerable.
He was in solitary confinement
for over two years.
When he finally gets out,
he's basically lost his mind.
And I think three years later,
he's committed suicide, right?
So I just want to make clear
this is the [INAUDIBLE] point
that I made earlier.
When we think
about the suffering
in 16th and 17th century
Europe and the suffering
that these women had to
face in their own lives
in late medieval Europe,
much of that suffering
was kind of present and
real, whereas we conveniently
throw our suffering into boxes
far away that we can't see.
So I said that I wasn't going
to cause you pain and suffering.
And I have, I
hope, a little bit.
But anyway, I also hope
I've enlightened you
a little bit about
the need to rethink
suffering in life
and in particular
in the history of philosophy.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]